Hey guys, it's Ryan this video. We're going to continue our talk on orthodontic tooth movement and
So we talked about biomechanics and mechanics we talked about how biomechanics can be
Broken down into these three components. So we're gonna start with types of tooth movement in this video
So what do I mean by that? Well, we talked about how much force you can apply you can change magnitude
You can apply a light force you can apply heavy force and that's our F here
But the actual pressure
That's felt by the PDL depends on not only the force but also the area of the PDL that's affected by that force
So the force divided by the area over which it's applied equals the pressure
So what area of the PDL is affected that depends on a type of movement you want to accomplish
so uncontrolled tipping is
I guess the easiest
Type of movement to get you put a bracket on the tooth here
you're pulling one direction and
The crown moves in the direction of the force and the root moves the other way
so what I want you guys to do is take like a pencil or pen or a highlighter or something put it flat on your desk and
put your finger
sort of
right on this X here and
The X represents the center of resistance, which is a fixed point
And in the case of a tooth, it's pretty much the halfway mark
Between the halfway mark among the embedded root
So any part of the root that's embedded in alveolar bone you take the halfway mark of that and that's your
center of resistance
So if you put your finger, you take the pencil and you kind of figure it out to be a tooth you put it a little bit
Further down and halfway so you put your finger on top of that and take the finger of the other hand and put it where the bracket
would be and then
Take that finger and push it to the left and you'll notice how as you do that
The crown moves in the direction that your finger is pushing and the root is rotating
The opposite direction and it's rotating about this point
So for uncontrolled tipping your center of rotation, which is not fixed that depends on how you're moving the tooth is
exactly at the center of resistance, which is a fixed point and
Because the tooth is moving this way the PDL that feels a compression will be here and here
Because this part of the tooth is moving the left that part of the tooth is moving to the right
And that's what feels the pressure
so this is
not too much of the PDL maybe about like a quarter of the entire PDL is
experiencing force and
The optimal force for tipping is 50 grams 50 grams pulling this way
We'll apply the right amount of pressure to these two areas of the PDL to cause bone remodeling and tooth movement
Now the MC-MF ratio which we'll talk about more in the next example is zero in this case because there is no couple
There is a moment of the force
Which is basically anytime you have a force that's not applied through the center of resistance if it's some distance away from the center of resistance
It's called it produces a moment and every moment will produce some form of rotation about some point
So you're if you're not pushing through the center of let's say your pencil on your desk
If you pushed right through the center of it, it's going to move straight across without a rotation
But as soon as you push like on the eraser end, it's going to start to rotate and that's the result of a moment
Which is a force some distance away from the center of resistance
So what about control tipping that means we're controlling we don't really like in the previous example
We don't really like how that root is kind of just floating in the opposite direction
That's why we call it uncontrolled
They call it control tipping when we're able to
Keep that root tip from moving so much in the opposite direction
We kind of keep the root tip where it is and just move the crown
So how do we do that? Well, that's where the couple comes in so
Put your so this time
You put your finger, you know in the same kind of area
at the center of resistance on the pencil and then
have your other finger where the bracket would be and
well actually here do this put your finger word about the bracket would be on your pencil and then on
Top right at the tip
Push a little bit lighter
But push to the right so if you put your one finger where the bracket is and push left and then that would cause just
simple tipping and if you put your other finger at the tip and push a little bit to the right you'll see how
the
It's a little bit tricky, but if you start fooling around with it
you'll start to see what's going on the crown is moving and you can keep the root tip where it is and
That's because the couple is
rotating the tooth and
Basically the opposite direction that it's going because of this moment. So this moment wants to rotate the tooth
So the crown moves left and the root tip moves right and then this couple is
pure rotation force that
Still lets the tooth translate, but it cancels out the rotation caused by this moment
So you can kind of think of it like if you were to apply a force through the center of resistance, which is impossible on a tooth
You would cause pure translation
If you apply a force some distance away from the center of resistance that causes some translation and
some rotation
And then if you when you apply a couple you just you cause pure rotation
so
You kind of want to anytime you're away from the center of resistance and you're pulling or pushing you have rotation and
translation
translation is the
Exired tooth movement most of the time and the rotation is the undesired tooth movement. So that's what you kind of want to
That's what you kind of have to counteract
with a couple and now this couple is
Can be formed when the wire sits in the bracket
Unevenly so if you're thinking okay, I have a patient that brackets on
I'm putting the wire into the brackets when you see that wire it kind of snaps into the bracket
it doesn't fit in passively and just slide right in you have to bend it in and
Push it in with a little bit of resistance and that
Snapping in and that that clues you into it's not sitting in passively it's sitting in actively in that bracket and
It causes a couple in that way
now
The ratio here is between oh
I should mention so the fourth optimal force for this is about 75 because you're loading a little bit more of the
PDL than the previous example and
Where this ratio was zero this ratio is between zero and one
the
the couple the moment of the couple is
Less than the moment of the force and that's why the ratio is like that and now
control tipping is sort of the
midpoint between
uncontrolled tipping and bodily movement and
Body movements where we kind of already talked about this we wish we could push through the center of resistance
We can't so we're forced to put the bracket here and pull this way
We get that undesired
Root tip movement the opposite direction and we counteract that with a couple but this time it's stronger
So you can do this again with the pencil where you put your finger where the bracket is and push left
And then you're at the tip of the pencil pushing the opposite direction and if you do it a certain way
You can get you can get it so that the pencil moves across the desk
Perfectly evenly so the whole thing is moving to the left in perfect translation
so I
I'm doing it. I wish I could show you like an overhead map
But if you put your finger to the right of the pencil about say like three quarters of the way down
you push it you put your finger on the right of it and push left and
Then you put your finger at the tip on the left side and push right and if you do that you can actually move the pencil to the left
Perfectly
Evenly so hopefully that makes sense. Hopefully you can try that and see what's going on here. It's pretty cool and
Here we're loading a whole half of the PDL
So that's a hundred so you can kind of see how we had 50 here when about a quarter was loaded
we have doubled at when half is loaded and
The music the the moment of the couple
And moment of the force are equal in this case because they're canceling each other out there
The rotations are canceling out so we only get pure translation. So that's why it's one
And again, you can see how this is the midpoint between the two because we have 75
Which is between 50 and a hundred and we have a ratio between zero and one
so hopefully that makes sense because that's that's kind of a nice way to
Think about it. I think and then torque is taking
bodily movement one step further instead of not just moving the tooth
evenly now we want to move the root in the direction of the force so we make the couple even stronger to
Push the so you could put your fingers in the same area and then just push a little bit harder
On in this direction, and you can actually move the root tip in the left direction
and keep the crown kind of steady and
Because we're again, we're kind of back to applying about three quarters of the loading about three quarters of the PDL
very
Roughly and that would be about 75 grams
somewhere between 50 and a hundred at least and
Here the couple as we said is stronger than the moment of the force. So
That's how the ratio is greater than one
It's also called root operating and this torque is not to be confused with like the facial lingual
Torquing, which is like a third-order bend. That's kind of different
So just try to keep that in mind. This is a little this is a different this. We're talking purely like how the tooth is moving
Intrusion is pretty simple. That's just pushing down because it's
Loading such a small area the PDL. We only want 10 grams of pressure. Otherwise, we're not going to get intrusion
We're going to get other types of movement. We'll activate other parts of PL. So I have to keep it super super light
And it's about one millimeter per month is like an average of how much intrusion you could get
Oh, I also want to go back and just mention the centers of rotation. I kind of I forgot to mention some of that
So we did mention that the center of rotation here is exactly
For uncontrolled tipping the center of rotation is at the center of resistance for the control tipping
It's at the root tip because that's what was staying stationary for bodily movement. There really isn't one
It's kind of at infinity point
Some infinite infinite point away from the root tip because it's just moving. It's not really rotating. It's just moving
Straight across so there's not really a center rotation and then for torque
It's moved towards the crown because the roots the thing rotating
So hopefully that makes sense when you do the pencil and you kind of push stuff around on the table
You can see how things are rotating
And then for this is this idea of having one optimal force is pretty important. So depending on how you're moving the tooth
There's you know, here's the tooth movement ideal tooth movement. Here's the amount of pressure you're you're
exerting on the PDL and
The tooth movement gets better and better and better up to some optimal force and then pass the optimal force
It's kind of a plateau and maybe it drops off people don't really know
and
Anything beyond this optimal force is really not not needed. So we want to keep it there and
The optimal force depends on the type of tooth movement
So like we talked about the 50 grams for uncontrolled tipping which also is the same for extrusion and rotation
Which I didn't mention because they're kind of
Pretty straightforward, but it's also important to know that those are 50 grams as well
And then if you're doing bodily movement, it's a hundred grams and so on
So it's also dependent on the tooth that you're moving
So if you're moving an incisor versus a molar the molar has way more
Especially if it's multi rooted has way more PDL areas that force is gonna have to be higher
So instead of 50 grams for uncontrolled tipping
Maybe you need like 80 or 90 if there's more PDL to be moved to be compressed
So there's one but there is always one optimal force per tooth per tooth movement
Alright guys, that's all I have for this video. So hopefully this was helpful. Thanks for watching and I'll see you guys next time